hey everyone how are you I am so excited
because right now I am about to unbox
the PlayStation for Juggernog black ops
3 special edition and I also have a
little helper Madi hello welcome to the
other side oh sorry
are you trying to help me or are you
just making things more difficult for me
here entertain yourself with that cool
look at we gods we've got the game oh
yeah look fabulous what's in here Maddy
I actually don't know what's in here
coasters Oh coasters okay but yeah open
it oh no these are cool at the speed
cool
the Juggernog the revive soda all Maddy
you're gonna you're real excited about
this aren't you I won't put this back on
here as long gonna get it back off some
more things are in here we've got the
season pass so personalized gun camos
new tab bonus mat multiplayer this is
what I'm super pumped about don't touch
these because you will eat them and I
need them they're like some little
player cards of all the specialists and
it says all of the things that they
could do on the back now time front
we've all been waiting for the
instructions safety installations and
instructions they first announced this
is like damn guys did it right
oh my gosh ah it is so fantastic I'm
putting this in my office and I love all
of my favorite drinks in it like water a
great idea oh this ah Maddy look what's
inside hey that's that's not that's not
for you
ice goes up up top here so we're gonna
plug this in test it out right here ah
thank you so much what a good boy for
bringing me the instructions you're a
really great unboxer now let it go okay
ah I knew that
alright we're asking me to go over here
because it's not gonna second reach
she's plugged in
let's turn this light on look at this
oh my god I love it
I'm so pumped for zombies I'm gonna lose
my freakin mind
well there you guys have it this is the
awesome little fridge that comes with
the special edition of the black ops 3
this is so sweet this is pretty I'm so
excited
what if it's cold yet but I put my
drinks in here not cold yet guys I'll
see you soon thank so much for watching
let me know what console you plan on
playing black ops 3 on leave you some
comments below and let me know what
addition that you guys got and if
anybody else got the juggernaut Edition
let me know what you think when you guys
finally do get it I'm pretty pumped I'm
gonna play call of duty now because this
is I this is great but I need to play
the game it's great it's fantastic it's
fantastic see ya it's been great it says
the first project that I've actually
produced from like the very beginning
although through the finished thing